so for me I typically like to wear like
slouchy oversized t-shirts kind of like
oh yes so John you're obviously wearing
johnelliott
today right let's check out a little bit
more Michael come on in here ladies and
gentlemen Michael Lockley hello I always
wanted kind of like a super tailored
pair of sweats and the only place I ever
saw it was like the 80s era of like
cocaine soccer yeah obviously everything
I do is very much inspired by sports and
movement so that was just really
inspired by a pair of soccer pants from
the 80s so that's why I named invest
Mars that early spark was with this
sweatshirt that he's running right now
we call it the villain hoodie the first
store that I ever worked in in San
Francisco which is no longer was called
villain so like an ode to where I
started to pull over hoodie with two
side zippers concealing a hidden
kangaroo pocket but yes I was watching
YouTube videos of Joe Montana in the
playoffs against the New York Giants and
I don't know what year was in the
playoffs he got destroyed by Lawrence
Taylor and his Jersey got untucked and
he puts his hand underneath like the
jersey into the hand warmer and it was
like boom and so that was really the
spark that was the idea i sat there and
started sketching it you know next thing
I know I was wearing it in a bar and it
was like that was like the first litmus
test that okay this is this is gonna
work I knew that if we kind of had some
traction from the store staff then they
would push this stuff right you know I
worked on the floor for five years
selling clothes and I understand that
psychology of what goes into making a
guy pick something up off a rack yeah
the stuff it was it was sold out in the
week they called for a reorder we had
nothing hey I got what three what yeah
so Jiki we've been following what you've
been doing for a while but one really
cool moment was in February where you
had your first runway show extremely
nervous a little bit scared but also you
know you never really get a second
chance to do something for the first
time did a producer say Ocana just
showed up I mean for him
I'm through and so someone passed it
down the lines is someone within my team
that guy on a dead sprint John Cho God
yeah here yeah he's a generational
creative right you know any time that
you have any kind of face time with
someone like that it's special they
weren't in the first collection we had
our second collection we're taking it to
Vegas to actually start showing
wholesale accounts we for one types of
people who are interested in seeing the
line right and so we were outside of LA
County and my business partner Aaron
Levite hits me goes you brought the
sweats right I said you know what I
didn't bring them I don't think we're
gonna show them I don't think it fits in
the line and I it goes to [ __ ] pull
the car around
goes back we go and get them right time
right pant right silhouette people were
trying them on and it was just like hey
thanks gentlemen
thank you uh preciate it man all right
cool